Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters. Again, we're going to interview a great person today.
Lease Genome works at Designs for Health, where we get our product, several of our products,
that we private label, and what is a product called Curcuclear. So,
Lease, you and I were talking about what is a good topic to talk about. You suggested that. That's
one of our biggest sellers, and it's because we believe so highly in it. What we are dealing with
with chronic inflammation, which is so common with everybody, you know, anybody with a disease
process. Curcumid is one of the things that you think of, and when you talk about research data
on natural cancer killers, there's probably not anything as research as curcumid.
So, let's talk about this product and your expertise at it. So, why is the Curcuclear product
the best of the market right now? Well, basically, we are delivering Curcumid
in the highest absorbable form, and that's really what makes it unique. It goes through a special
process called an e-vail process that is proprietary to us, and basically what that process is doing
is it's wrapping the Curcumin molecule, which is hard to absorb. We're wrapping it in a fat,
and that fat helps shuttle the Curcumin across major gut obstacles and blood brain obstacles.
So, I remember back in the day before this product existed, we used to use a powder
tumeric that was wrapped in a coconut oil, but there wasn't a lot of research data on that product.
It just seemed like it was the best thing that we had at the time. And prior to that, we used to
tap to people take tumeric with coconut oil. And so, of course, it wasn't wrapped in that fat. You
just had fat in the gut at the same time as you had the tumeric, which wasn't the best way to do it,
because, you know, it doesn't necessarily help in the tumeric to get across the gut barrier.
And that's the key to most supplements. You can take a lot of different things that they could just
end up in the toilet if you don't absorb them. They don't do anything good. As you said, in the
beginning, it's one of the most well-researched compounds out there. And really, when you get down
to the base of it, it's got two different actions, which is why it's so effective in the body.
One is that it's one of the strongest antioxidants out there. And then second, it works on two
anti-inflammatory pathways in the body. And that is, especially that second part is what makes it
pretty unique out there because a lot of your more common substances that you can get your hands
on are only going to work on one of those pathways. So, if you're talking about its antioxidant
properties, the reason why you would be concerned with that is because there's a lot of things in your
life that are going to cause oxidative stress, not getting enough or the right kinds of sleep. If
you're a smoker, if you're under chronic stress, if you've got an injury, all of these things
are going to cause oxidative stress. And then chronic oxidative stress ongoing is going to cause
oxidative damage. And that's been recognized to be one of the main factors underlying in a lot,
lots of diseases out there. So, that's why you'd want to be concerned with getting antioxidants.
So, as far as listeners out there that may not understand, they hear, oh, I should be taking
anti-oxidants. Well, what is oxidative stress in the first place? We talk about cancer,
oxidative stress is a major cause of cell damage, DNA damage, and then a cell going into rapid
replication, which is cancer. And like you said, most diseases, all degenerative diseases out there
have a factor of oxidative stress. So, getting antioxidants is important. And the source of oxidative
stress is endless. We live in just a poise of the world, right? So, as it's antioxidant factor,
that's probably one of the most research pieces of curcumin is so beneficial. I'm sorry, so go
on with that then. Oh no, I was just going to add one last piece is that, you know, in the modern
diet, we're just not getting high antioxidant foods in our diet on a regular basis to help kind
of combat that overload. So, you know, that's where curcumin supplementation comes into play.
Yeah, our foods are pretty stripped of nutrients, aren't they?
Right. The second action of it is working on those two anti-inflammatory pathways.
So, while it's doing all these wonderful things, helping to sort of downregulate all those
all the oxidative stress going on in your body, it's working on those two pathways. And it's helping
to decrease something called NF capa beta, which is basically sort of like the mother of an
inflammatory response that can go awry in a lot of chronic diseases.
So, nuclear factor capa beta is the key inflammatory response that can be overexpressed in a lot of
diseases, right? And certainly with cancer patients as well as line patients in any inflammatory
process it's going on. And curcumin has been shown time and again in research studies that it
comes that NF capa beta expression down, and that's a key component for decreasing that in
inflammation. We talk a lot about nothing is all good or all bad like inflammation has a purpose
too. It's not that we don't want any inflammation. We just don't want chronic overexpressed inflammation.
The nice thing about curcumin is it won't shut off that acute necessary inflammation in case of
like an injury or a infection where you need a ramped up immune system. It doesn't shut that
piece down. It shuts down that NF capa beta chronic inflammation down, and that's so key. We talk
about that with our cancer patients a lot. We want to ramp up a acute inflammation response in
like fighting the infection, fighting the disease, fighting cancer, but we don't want that chronic
inflammation that blocks the immune cells, ability to even get to a cancer or a bacteria or anything.
So, or give it is just a great way to control both of those things. Yeah, I hope support a healthy
inflammatory response. Right. Exactly. Anything else you have to say about the tetrahedral
curcuminoid that you're so full of? Yeah, I would say I love this formula because it sort of mimics
the way that it's found in nature. So, we're wrapping it in a fat, we're getting, we're shuttling it
across these barriers, and then we're also pairing it with turmeric oil. And that is how curcumin
is found in nature. It's found within the turmeric root, along with all those phytochemicals found
in the oil. And the awesome thing about those phytochemicals is that they have also been researched
and shown to help enhance absorption. So, it's just a really nice synergistic and very effective
formula. Yeah, I love it. We I take it myself and I know a lot of our patients take it.
It even for a person who doesn't have any serious disease, taking one a day can be real beneficial,
person who has a serious disease, taking two or three or even more. Does each pill has really
equivalent to almost a gram of curcumin? It does. It's a great way that you don't have to take as
many pills as some of them are out there because of the absorption. Exactly. Yeah, and who I mean
everyone gets on pill fatigue. So, yeah, less is good, if you can get there. Well, thanks so much
for being on with us today. I'm going to have you back again, if you are so willing to talk about
some other products that we love so much that your company makes. Oh yeah, I'd love to. Thanks for
having me. I appreciate your expertise. And you can find the curcuclear as well as our other
products on our store. We'll put links up on this page as well. Thank you. Goodlace. I appreciate it.
Thanks, Dr. Connors. Bye bye.